[Music]  there's a war coming  sam's brother this spy game this is my  world  careful careful when you get hurt  [Music]  fast and furious franchise it's kind of  unique  it really sheds light on the female  voice in action movies  [Music]  which is why it's so exciting to have so  many badass women in fastnine  all right mia you're up  fast females take ownership of it  [Music]  they raise the bar get your breakfast  they do the unexpected  and i think that's what makes us  inferior rather special  in this movie we're not holding back  when it comes to the action  it's freaking fast and furious  also furious women get to show the world  what they can do  [Music]  that's what makes it so cool  [Music]  you